Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday
Thank you for the brilliant and astonishingly comprehensive
After seeing it, I went on Twitter
and asked eligible American voters
who don't intend to vote
what their reasoning was,
and today I wanna respond to the six concerns I heard the most.
number one by far:
"I do not wanna choose between the lesser of two evils"
Two things; first in most states there will be more than two candidates on the presidential ballot.
secondly, I think maybe you do wanna choose between the lesser of two evils.
you know, because it's the less evil choice.
By not voting you're essentially ranking the candidates as equally evil
which I think is technically impossible
given their vastly different policy positions
Also, you're not just voting for President
I know it might feel that way
because of national media coverage
but the elections down the ballot are extremely important
It's not just your senators and US congresspeople
It's your state legislators who make the laws in your state,
the school board members, who decide what the curriculum is gonna look like in your schools.
Those elections have a massive effect on the community you live in.
Okay, concern number two:
"I am not informed on the issues and/or don't care"
So if you don't care who your elected representatives are,
we agree on this one,
you should not vote.
But it's not really that hard to get well informed,
you can go to:
Find your state.
Find the sample ballot
then you can go to the candidates' websites
or if it's a race for US Senate or Congress,
there's a great website called Ballotpedia
link in the Dooblydoo
and if you want us to make videos about candidates'
policy plans and proposals,
let us know in comments what topics you'd like for us to explore
Concern three:
"I'm a Republican in a 'blue state' or a Democrat in a 'red state', so my vote doesn't matter"
First, your down-ballot votes might matter
but I'd argue your vote matters regardless
like, you're right that your vote isn't gonna tip the election
but by not voting you're making politicians in your state believe
that their state is less politically diverse than it actually is
and I think that's dangerous because a strong minority has a moderating effect on the party in power
both at national and local levels
and God knows we could use some moderation
Concern four:
"the system is corrupted by money and votes don't actually matter"
I agree that the system is corrupted by money
I just don't think we're gonna fix it by not voting
because not voting out of protest looks, to the system,
exactly the same as not voting out of apathy
Also, I don't think money negates the power of your vote
and I think rich people know this actually
like, 57.5% of eligible American voters, voted in the 2012 election.
99% of millionaires did, literally.
Number five: illness or disability or transportation problems
One of my many frustrations with US voting laws is that
in lots of states it's really difficult to vote if you are sick or disabled.
But find your state in the links below and check out your options,
there usually are some.
Also, if you need a ride on election day
most local political parties will pick you up and take you to the polls even if you're not voting for their candidates.
Okay, lastly, number six:
"I am overwhelmed with the process of registering
and have never voted before, and find this whole thing intensely scary"
Yeah, I can relate
like 16 years ago in August of 2000
I'd just moved to Chicago,
but I didn't know where I technically lived.
Like, I was sleeping in a walk-in closet of a Chicago apartment
that my name wasn't on the lease of
but my driver's license said I lived with mom and dad
back in Florida, where most of my stuff was
and it was a stressful and overwhelming time,
and I had no idea how to register
and suddenly I looked up and the deadline had passed.
It's true that the system makes it hard for people who move around a lot to vote,
but I lacked the fortitude to stand up to that system,
and it is one of the great shames of my life.
I feel like I failed my community and myself,
and also people who live far away from me
who desperately want the opportunity that I took for granted.
Of course my vote wouldn't have changed the outcomes in any elections
but the combined votes of even 10% of the thousands of people who were like me
that would've changed some outcomes
If you're eligible to vote in the United States
I'm asking you to become a registered and informed voter,
and to make your voice heard,
even if it's hard.
In fact, especially if it's hard.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.